عنوان خبرنا الجاي هو اغلى جلسه ليزري
يمكن في التاريخ ففي ثلاثه من لاعبين نادي
الزمالك مصطفى شلبي ومحمد صبحي وعبد الله
جمعه نشر صور لهم في احدى عيادات الاطباء
المعروفين وهم بيعملوا جلسات ليزر لازاله
الشعر
والصور هذه كلفتهم 300,000 جنيه
الصور اللي شفتوها نشروها اللاعبين على
صفحاتهم الشخصيه وهو بيعملوا او هم
بيعملوا جلسات ليزر ويبدو ان دعايه لاحد
العياده ولكن رجعوا حذفوها من بعد
الانتقادات ففي ناس شايفه انه عيب نشر شيء
مثل هذا حتى لو كانوا بيعملوا ليزر وانا
شايف انه هذا مو من الرجوله اصلا
على التوقيت كان الصور نزلت والنادي
بيستعد لمباراه مهمه وفي ناس حاولوا
الموضوع لماده للنكت
بعد التعليقات والجدل والغضب اللي صار
اداره نادي الزمالك ووفق مصادر من داخل
النادي غير متلاعبين 300 الف جنيه لكن مو
واضح للانسه بالغرام يعني هي مشكلتهم في
الليزر ولا فكره الاعلان من اساسه ولا انه
اعلان غير لائق التوقيت ولا ايش ما نعرف
[موسيقى]